hello everyone I hope you're all having
an excellent today we are gonna take a
short break from the capablanca saga to
check up on the feeder worlds Team
Championship
it's a tournament taking place from 5th
to 14th in Kazakhstan Astana and 10
teams will be fighting for well the
title of a World Team Champion and it's
an it's an invitational so although that
all of the 10 teams have been invited I
know that Poland rejected their offer to
participate and instead of Poland Sweden
decided to participate we're gonna talk
a bit more about the teams after we
check up on this game and this is the
first game that were showing from this
championship and it's already round 3 so
we do have a bit catching up to do but I
really like this game I'm sure gonna
enjoy it
so before we check out the actual game
here are a couple of nice photos all the
photos are from the official
photographer David Lada so there we have
it as we are showing the game Napo
versus you jungie
there you have it the team of Russia
Sergey Carrick in an opponent she there
you have it Greece choke opening up his
a bowl of water and Ladislav artemiy all
the way in the back and there there is
this gentleman here I cannot recognize
him and it seems like he's showing
something to nip Oh hard hard to say
what it is could it could be a new shiny
belt buckle or something but yeah just a
very nice photo of the team and while
we're on the subject of belt buckles I
always thought it'd be really cool like
to have a belt buckle where we have like
a king and a rook and then if you buckle
your belt you know you just Castle I
always thought that would be nice I
don't think other people would think
it's nice I I just always thought it
that'd be something nice to have but
also here we have a photo a nice photo
of all of them before the game starts
there we have it the handshake is all
over the place for China there we have
it first board Bingley Rijn versus serie
Kirk in the new young e against nip oh
the game were just about to show then
we'ii versus outside of Greece you can
vladislav our team iam on the final
board against booze youngji the on board
for we're gonna talk a bit more about
the results after the game so let's
check it out it's a very exciting game a
lot of action going on and
well it's just it's just a nice game so
neppo opens with efore sorry about that
one of the few times that I actually
forgot to do this e5 and Knight to f3
Knight to f6 and d4 now
so the petrels defense is on the board
we have the shine it's attack
Knight captures on e4 Bishop to d3 and
now d5 this is all standard standard
theory of the petrov of the Steinitz
attack Knight captures on e5 and now
Knight to d7 captures captures and here
white just castles we have Bishop to d6
and now Knight to c3 preparing to
capture the night here Knight captures B
captures on c3 black doesn't want to
waste any time and now black just
castles so here it's a one of those
quick variations where all of the
Knights are exchanged already I'll move
9 and both players are left with a
bishop pair so it's always you know
you're playing the game you think okay I
have a bishop pair my position is great
but then all of a sudden your opponent
also has the bishop pair so it's really
really just crazy and here nipple goes
for Queen to h5 seems like a very
barbaric plan but it's also the best
plan because you're already threatening
checkmate so you don't have to block it
you don't want to ruin your position a
bit too much by going g6 then the Queen
moves maybe Bishop to h6 comes in so so
first we have f5 now okay the bishop
controls the f5 pawn the pawn blocks the
bishop so there are no threats here rook
to e1
nepo develops the rook c6 and Bishop to
g5 attacking the Queen Queen to c7 and
here it's move 12 and already this
position has been played for example one
of the stronger players who have reached
this position in 2009 in the World Cup
is Maxine Michelle lagravis is Boris
Gelfand where c4 was played and c4 is in
fact the strongest more recommended by
the engine but it seems that neppo
either nudists and he prepared something
else or perhaps he just has an
inspiration over the board and he goes
rook to e3 a very nice rook lift I'm
much more you know enjoyable move I'm
more aesthetically pleasing move if you
will
the threat is rook to h3 already
doubling up on the H file and the wealth
Queen would very
much like to capture on h7 so if you did
something like rook a to a then Luke 2 H
3 would be very dangerous for example
you have to block now you have to play
h6 and white can just grab here but
strip captures and you cannot even
capture back if you capture back then of
course you are getting checkmated so a
lot of poison to this rook lift by net
for Luke III you have to first kick away
the Queen this is what young II does we
have g6 Queen to h4 and not only now
rook 88 with hopes of exchanging rooks
neppo doubles up now rook to h3 isn't
all that impressive because there are
various ways that you can defend the h7
point you can go rook rook e7 Luke f7
are you gonna go bishop c8 and then the
Queen also defends the h7 pawn so rook
to h3 here is not not so powerful so
first rook 81 you do want to develop you
know all of the pieces before you start
any you know rather decisioning rook
captures on d3 rook captures and now
rook to e8 young he wants to exchange
the other pair of rooks as well and only
now see for a very principled idea your
C point is doubled you do want to trade
it for blacks very strong d5 point and
also you know if black captures then
always you of course have this diagonal
for your bishop which will be very nice
rook captures on d3 first Bishop
captures on e3 and now Bishop to ei so
the Queen can now come back into the
game and here we have c5 pushing the
bishop back the asking basically do want
to go Bishop to e7 attack my queen then
I will just go back up to g5 trade
bishops but rather young he goes
Queen to e7 he wants to trade Queens
immediately and here we have Bishop to
g5 now the queen is attacked and also
the bishop here is still attacked so
what does black do Queen t1 check Bishop
to f1 blocking
only move and now just Bishop to FA the
bishop will be very useful here you
don't want to allow something like
Bishop here Queen here and then all of a
sudden white is threatening checkmate so
a very nice defending piece on f8 this
dark square bishop we have Bishop to e3
now blocking the Queen's control of the
e-file so black would may very much like
to retreat let's say Queen e7 in hope of
trading Queens mo
the Queen will be a very nice defensive
piece but now white pretty much locked
the Queen out of the house so the Queen
has to find a different way how to get
back into the game here Young Eagles
Queen to F into a five if he wants to go
Queen to c7 and maybe the Queen can now
rejoin the defense rush up to f4
blocking the c7 square now the Queen is
controlling d8 this bishop is
controlling c7 so there's not not a lot
of ways that the Queen can get back into
the game first black goes Bishop to f7
we have Queen to f6 now infiltrating
with the Queen now there are of course
ideas Bishop to Bishop to e5 followed by
Queen to h8 would be deadly
so first you have to kick away the Queen
we have the g7 and now comes Queen to d6
and here put into e1 if you if you went
for the d4 pawn for example the ship
captures then you get Queen b8 check
after King to g7 you get Bishop to d6
now threatening all sorts of ideas and
after Bishop the g8 you do have to make
some room for a kingdom h8 otherwise
Queen to f6 is coming so Bishop here but
now Queen captures with chair King h8
and now Queen to e7 and the black will
have a very unpleasant position here
where he will constantly have to keep an
eye on this diagonal for example if
you're not careful or something let's
say we grab a pawn then white can even
sacrifice the Queen for a very nice
Bishop checkmate here
the King has nowhere to go as his own
light square Bishop is blocking his path
so after this Queen to d6 move we have
Quinta II won first now the Queen wants
to come back into the game via the
e-file and nipple just closes the e-file
once again with Bishop to e3 and now
comes Bishop to f8 attacking the Queen
forcing the Queen to move Queen to b8
now threatening to pick up the pawns
from the Queen side and while black was
able to prevent any checkmating ideas he
had to allow at least some loss of
material in favor of white so b6 here we
have pawn captured sorry pawn captures
pawn captures and Queen captures nipple
grabs upon and by doing this he created
a very strong past a pawn now so even if
white doesn't do anything regarding any
checkmating ideas he can just push his
passed pawn and he wins
game so black has to do something about
this we have Quinta a1 now of course you
cannot pull the pawn as black will just
win it
Queen to a7 now just defending the pawn
and now black doesn't really have all
that many active ideas what black wants
to do is somehow break through the
center
that's why c5 is played and perhaps if
you know that things happen then maybe
maybe just maybe this Bishop can come to
c4 and threaten some checkmating the
ideas you know of its own Queen to a
first now
pinning the bishop here Bishop to h6
will be a deadly threat so let's say you
play D captures on c5 here like we
mentioned in just d4 is very strong and
now after we move the bishop let's say
anywhere then the shop to c4 it was the
plan
just to explain c5 but okay Queen to 8
and now you don't really have a good way
of preventing this if you go King g7
still Bishop to h6 wins the game King
capture screen captures with check King
has to move now you lose the other
Bishop as well and well white is just up
a bishop and winning so after the screen
to a move young he finds a different
plan
Queen 31 now the idea is after this
Bishop to h6 move you can just defend
with Queen to 8 so not not to the
greatest of plans
so instead after this Queen to you one
move first we have D captures in c5 nepo
just takes this opportunity to create
yet another very strong passed pawn
which is not even closer to becoming a
queen
d4 now attacking the bishop but also
threatening Bishop to c4 again if you
capture the pawn you get Bishop to c4
black is now winning as Queen captures
and f1 will be deadly so after d4 we
have Bishop to h6 white cannot afford to
waste time now of course you cannot play
Bishop to c4 due to Queen captures on f8
with checkmate
so Bishop the ei8 blocking we have Queen
to d5 check Bishop to f7 now and now
Queen to d8
again threatening to capture here and
now you you cannot block again if you
try something like the Bishop to Bishop
here then black is pretty much tied down
just c6 will win the game your threats
to bring your queen into the game if you
capture sorry not to that the bishop is
another night if you capture them Queen
captures on f8 so after Queen to d8 we
have Queen to e7 now black has to bring
the Queen back into the defense but now
it is far too late never goes Queen
captures we have Bishop captures and now
c6 the threat of course is c7 and c8 so
young he stops the pawn Bishop to b6
controlling the c7 square we have g3 now
Knepper has plans of now playing Bishop
to f4 to exchange the dark square Bishop
so the pawn can continue advancing
forward
Bishop to d5 is threatening to capture
and c6 but now again a very nice move
just a for Bishop to b5 was also
possible but a far a 4 is just a much
nicer move because now is better
captures you get Bishop to c4 check the
King has nowhere to go King has to go to
88 and now you just push a 5 and with
the black King being cut off from the
game completely and there's no way this
King is ever coming back into the game
white is just gonna bring the King into
the game maybe maybe when when the d4
pawn and then get closer the the bishop
pair will now control all of the
important squares that are needed for
pushing of this pawn and black king will
just be stuck there in the corner yeah
you know watching helplessly
so after this a4 move we have King to f7
bringing the King into the game of
course and only now Bishop to b5
defending Bishop to c7 so black decided
it was better just to you know keep the
pawn alive but activate the King in and
in the endgame you know a king is just
as valuable as any other piece sometimes
even more valuable
sometimes Bishop to c7 blocking the pawn
but also controlling the a5 square we
have Bishop to f4 now white even offers
to double double his own F F born just
to get rid of this you know controller
of the dark squares so but should
captures pawn captures and now King g7
black finally gets his King into the
center of the board but now c7 the
Bishop and pawn are preventing the King
from reaching the d8 or d7 square so you
do have to play something
Bishop to b7 preventing the pawn from
Queeny
and now just a 5 and it was in
position on move 44 that Chinese
Grandmaster youngy resigned the game and
a very nice victory for an opponent she
who whose victory got Russia a full two
points because here when you win a game
you get two two match points at Roble we
knew one match point and of course a
loss will win you know match points but
yeah a very nice game by nepo here black
resigns as there is no way to prevent
the queening of the pawn if you play
something like King these six you have
to bring the King into the game just a
success coming and then it doesn't
really matter if you go Bishop create
then this pawn Queens if you play
something like this then again just a
seven threatening the Queen again you
have to block and then just any pawn
let's say bring a queen in the game
captures the other pawn Queens so
nothing to do here white always ends up
being up a queen so after this a five
move young resigned the game and with
this victory in round three of the
Phaedo World Team Championship Russia
takes first place here we have this from
the official feed a website there you
have it Russia with six match points
I thought China had a really good shot
at you know winning this as they did so
extremely well in the Olympics but here
only only one on day one only one match
so far the previous round around
- Alexandra Linderman want a very nice
game so and all the other games were
drawn so China lost against the United
States in the previous round and now
with this victory by an opponent she
over Bianchi also full two match points
so Russia is now in first place followed
by India with five and USA with five
England would five then Iran with three
Kazakhstan with three China which do you
know very very hard to see China so far
back but you know it's it's a tough
competition then Azerbaijan would one
and then Egypt with zero in Sweden who
took Poland's place in this championship
as opponent for some reason declined the
invitation I don't know why they
declined maybe it was just maybe they
just didn't feel like playing but I
don't think that's it if anyone has some
insight to this why Poland the declined
the invitation do share in the comments
we'll of course pin your comment or give
it a heart so everyone else can see it
but yeah that's the game I really do
hope you enjoyed it I really enjoyed it
because it was a very very normal game
we're just both players have the bishop
pair and then just you know little
little details mattered where black was
constantly trying to trade the Queen
trade of Queen trade a queen nipple did
not allow it he create little advantages
and then when black finally was able to
trade the Queen it was far too late as
you know neppo already had to past bones
which were just do strong but yeah once
again I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Tony Clemens Mark Huberty
then is the young Carol Krinsky and Tom
Estrada for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video so you're thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content we're gonna check up on games
from the World Team Championship and we
are definitely continuing the Capablanca
saga also thanks to David Lada for such
nice photo so I will put a couple useful
links in the description below where you
can also follow his work and follow the
official feed a feed their streams and
feed a channels ok thank you all and I
will see you soon